pour une maison sur les hauteurs de
besançon le prix est plutôt correct mais
pour l'association des amis du
funiculaire réunir 40 mille euros n'est
pas chose aisée alors une souscription a
été lancée sur internet
chacun pourra donc participer au
sauvetage de cet élément du patrimoine
bisontin
mise en service en 1912 le funiculaire à
transporter des générations de bisontins
entre beauregard et bregy trois minutes
10 pour effectuer 420 m en 1971 la télé
est encore en noir et blanc et le
funiculaire transporte cent mille
voyageurs par an mais le déclin est en
route des moyens de transport personnels
se sont développées le moteur automobile
delphi et par dessus le marché des
autobus urbains désert actuellement le
plateau projet constitue un concurrent
important en 1987
le funiculaire effectué son dernier
voyage le temps a fait son oeuvre mais
pas de manière irrémédiable
depuis quinze ans l'association réunit
tous les éléments d'un vaste puzzle avec
une ambition redémarrer le funiculaire
le funiculaire devrait avoir une
affectation oui partagé entre une
vocation patrimoniale bien sûr c'est le
fondement de notre association
et puis une fonction touristique
attractive
et puis aussi fonctionnel parce qu'il ya
quand même des gens qui nous disent ah
ben moi aussi fonctionné je le prendrai
au lieu de me taper la protéger des
intempéries la salle des machines n'a
pas bougé difficile toutefois d'imaginer
qu'elle puisse reprendre du service à
l'identique
deux autres funiculaire à evian et au
mont d'or en auvergne circulent de
nouveau de la station de beauregard une
des deux cabines restaurée est prête à
repartir à l'assaut de la colline jugés
désuets dans les années 80 le
funiculaire pourrait comme le tramway
revenir au goût du jour moque de
circulation propres économes en énergie
des atouts qui aujourd'hui sont loin
d'être négligeables